can white people get white people can
white people say white people or can
white people can white people can they
say the N word we'll say the N word say
the N word say the n-word can white
people say the n-word
[Music]
oh no
why do you can't say the n-word no they
can't no no why not because they can't
buy no no yeah yeah no it's certain
types you know what I'm saying it's just
a word
as if you my friend anyway it's a choice
if they want to because pretty diverse
answers to be honest yeah absolutely I
keep going I want to know more no
I hate this
[ __ ] he didn't say it can white people
say to n word
right
yep that's me you're probably wondering
how I ended up in this situation well it
all started when I thought it'd be funny
if I paid white people a dollar to say
the n-word on camera for one dollar
[Music]
would you say the n-word no what's the
N-word most of discrimination oh inward
the blacks themselves the blacks
themselves as they say hey my Nick but
that part will come later promote that
nowadays they don't promote it they
promote it between themselves wrong
they're still promoting between
themselves this is the part where black
people share their opinion on the word
that once meant slave but today doesn't
really seem to mean anything at all
excuse me can white people say the N
word hell no why not
why the [ __ ] would that little white
person inward can white people say the
n-word
[Music]
[ __ ] can say it no can I say it can
you say it yeah kind of look like a
[ __ ] isn't it pretty funny how because
he looks like a little he's he looks
less white that he just like
automatically gets the pass yeah it's
kind of a strange Dynamic I wonder how
that like that started where like
Spanish people and different anyone not
white essentially you get you just get
you get the pass I think it's it's just
been used with such Venom that I
understand fully understand the
bristling to it like why people are
sensitive about why people like up yours
[ __ ] you know so if you if you hurt
if you're hood and you're a person of
color you could say it in a sins what
about a white person from the hood and
it depends on the circumstance yeah it
says it right there in the shirt oh
sorry no yeah I go there too that's why
she says the N word all the time she's
Russian some people say only Hispanics
and black people should be what about
people like me
aren't you Hispanic
2018. in 2018 okay Donald Trump is the
[ __ ] president my [ __ ] she gets a
black card we gotta let go of this stuff
and stop focusing on it because the more
you focus on the problem all you see is
the damn problem like the solution to
racism stop talking about it so much if
all you do is mention it when you're
when you talk to little kids and you
start talking to them about how to be
anti-racist little kids are dumb the
kids are gonna think it's funny to then
go and make fun of the black kid because
you're constantly talking about not
doing it like I remember even if it's
not that all they see then is is race
and color that's all exactly they see it
naturally I remember I didn't even I I
didn't even like really realize race and
color until like third grade when it was
taught to us and I remember I had like a
black friend Jaden in in elementary
school I remember this and I remember
thinking like it's so weird like having
when they started talking about race so
much I was like it was just such a weird
realization that like people disliked
others for their skin color and like why
that was important I remember but like
I'm I'm in third grade thinking that why
are you why are you telling this to kids
since they're three years old just let
them grow up as kids and stop talking
about racism so much and it'll go away
you know what I mean because once that
happened to me then you're thinking
about race way more rather than just as
like one of my peers you get what you
focus on Mother Teresa I've read this
years ago and it's so powerful for me in
a way of operating my life she was all
about peace and she had been invited to
many anti-war rallies and she said do
not invite me to an anti-war rally I
will not go if you invite me to a peace
rally I will join you it's about energy
too it's about energy and putting and
and but but just think about that for a
minute that one of the most kind
examples wonderful people of modern
history who is known there's nobody
nobody has anything bad to say about
this woman nothing there's nothing there
yeah but wonderful kindness and
generosity of spirit and she said I will
only put my energy into peace not into
anti-war because if you just go more
World War you're going to get more World
War and that operates on every single
right down to the most minuscule thing
in our lives and I think it's really
beautiful and I think it's important and
I think we could all learn from it
energy goes with a lot of different
things with business being confident
just being positive that positive energy
comes back around and it's not easy and
it's not damn exhausting being
optimistic and positive it really is I
mean let's not we're not going to
pretend that it's easy you know what's
crazy is I remember back when we were at
the house over there you were like talk
nice to the plants and I was like what
the [ __ ] is the matter with you talk
nice to the plant are you actually
losing it and now I'm like wow energy is
real and doing stuff like that is proven
to make them healthier and and look
better you just walk by the plant and be
like bro you looking good today and it
feels it it's the strangest phenomenon
but even Einstein talked about it how
all the top metaphysical energy that we
can't see with our eyes that's going
back and now if we could see where their
eyes you would see it between us on this
film right now but we're not there yet
technology if all the top people most
successful people are talking about it
why would you at least listen and try it
you know what I mean those dudes know
more than where like we are so yeah I'm
gonna listen to him get that car because
she's dating you yes absolutely yeah you
don't feel like you're selling out just
a little bit no not at all there's no
sellouts he just said she's got a black
card because she's Hispanic and it's his
girl that's funny but it's cute it's
cute
I don't know is Eminem and he still
don't say it
what's an Eminem bro come on I don't
have my rapper Eminem Oh I thought I
thought it was about the Blackheart I
think you're saying the only person I
give my card to is Eminem but he doesn't
even use it oh okay no he knows he's
white oh I was here
a little mix thing
but yeah and what's the logic that they
can use the n-word because they weren't
even the ones oppressed by it so I don't
even understand like the people as well
no no no no no no I'll correct you there
in saying that I'm just trying to get I
get annoyed when people who speak for
the black community like slavery slavery
slavery I'm like listen you're not
catching any of our ears with that
because we all agree that that sucks and
it's over and right from the very
beginning of this country there were
people who were anti-slavery it just
took unfortunately way too long for it
to become something that was put into
law where it was where it was abolished
and then it took even longer for it to
actually like get out of practice the
the people today who are feeling
oppressed have actual gripes that I do
believe are real in today's context
there was no doubt and any white judge
or prosecutor will tell you the data
shows that white criminals given the
same you know same misdemeanor theft uh
pot cocaine and eight is is 19 year old
white kid in Martha's Vineyard gets
caught with some Coke versus the 19 year
old black kid in Mattapan that gets
caught with some coke they are going to
have a very different results there is
no question that there is uh racism and
in the system and in in in in the
community so if they would focus on
those things truly I think they would
have so many more people going hell yeah
but when you're complaining about [ __ ]
that happened 200 years ago like enough
nobody want like now you're losing
people and I understand the reasoning
for doing that but like we really do
have valid arguments when we say all of
us have had [ __ ] in our histories
going back to the beginning of time God
look at the Jews I mean they've been
persecuted for from the beginning of
recorded history and they have
persevered and built and built and been
like up yours all of you we are gonna
take over and go get them they have
they're wonderful their doctors their
lawyers their business tycoons so I
think the messaging is just wrong and
and some of that is race race baited
race based and some of it is
socioeconomics because again the poor
white kid with the same charge as the
rich white kid poor white kid [ __ ]
doomed doomed no I would agree that the
um judicial system is definitely biased
against like people of color and stuff
like that yes but but the left was so
bad about was showing that because they
would compare apples to oranges in a lot
of scenarios and show like two complete
like the judicial system like two cases
can't like really just be compared like
it's very rare that you have two cases
that you can compare down to the T and
so what they do is they take someone
with like a whole ass criminal record
doing something and then someone without
a criminal record and then they do
something kind of similar and then
they'd be like well it's race and it's
like well no it's not always because of
that you know what I mean but no it's
not but I did I did talk to
um a very very close person in my life
who has been a prosecutor in a major
United States city and she'll grow okay
she even she acknowledges the the things
I just said misdemeanors theft assault
basic [ __ ] that there are big
differences in how blacks versus whites
get treated or low income and Hispanics
versus you know middle income and above
whites she acknowledges just totally she
say yeah absolutely has changed but she
did say gun charges you bring a gun
doesn't matter if you're a white kid
from a good family or a black kid you're
screwed either you you from wherever
good bad or indifferent judge is not on
your side no one's on your side at that
point so she she was really clear about
that and she has Decades of experience
in it so it really depends but what I
what I really appreciated was it's good
that you get your information from like
a reliable source like a friend that you
know will tell you extremely reliable
rather than the media I'm just listening
to everything you see on Brittany's
Instagram stories you know yeah Brittany
don't know [ __ ] not Britney Spears I
love her just for clarity if you're
raised in the urban area and you white
all right thank you thank you you want
you want to talk I want to serve damn
you [ __ ] say the n-word about
what yo Johnson Guido you might have a
different answer than you though what's
what's the question what's the question
let me hold the mic let me ask the
question from Queen yeah it depends
where they're from though where are you
from I'm from Maryland
for real can you say it
he don't know where I'm from I'm from
the home place of Wale and logic both of
them [ __ ]
look at his stuff for you and also his
shirt is covered in drool or sweaters
yeah he probably threw up or something
if this guy says the n-word Are You
Really Gonna Knock Out uh an
unconsciously drunk guy because he says
the n-word or are you gonna be the
bigger person and be like [ __ ] off like
just leave me alone you know what I mean
I mean hopefully you'll be a gentleman
and just keep moving roll your eyes and
keep moving because like if like if
Uncle do you know with the feeling of
when somebody pisses you off and you do
the right thing and then afterwards
you're like damn I wish I hadn't done
anything so it's not easy it's not no
it's either not knock someone out when
they really trigger when they press your
button no you don't have a button and so
I can't on the one hand yeah yes I
bought someone for knocking a little
drunk white ass dude out for saying it
if he says it like a douche I'm just
saying personally and on the other hand
I'm like please just let's all be ladies
and gentlemen well like what I'm saying
is in a scenario where I'm the person
who's um there's a drunk guy insulting
me who I could obviously just like kick
the [ __ ] out of I'm not just gonna go
kick the [ __ ] out of him because
necessarily just because he insulted me
I would be the bigger person and be like
you're incoherently drunk I'm I'm just
gonna but it's not that simple for
everybody no I know and I'm saying
that's why I'm on both sides because
also if someone deserves to get knocked
out sometimes they deserve a knuckle
sandwich you've been raised in a in a
family word by the grace of God you were
not you know punched out every time you
said something wrong so some people they
were trained for that and whether or not
it's wrong or right like do we want to
reach that person and be like hey
there's another option that doesn't look
very convincing from you is that do not
get a path does he get a pass I don't
know if that gets a pass how do you feel
about these people talking [ __ ] about
your race man what's up
he lucky Asian awake so I'm guessing
you're white it's kind of look like a
[ __ ] aren't you Hispanic are you white
you look like he got some black you got
to be Puerto Rican or black I don't know
what you want I'm not gonna hold you if
y'all listening to music
what if they come up to you and say why
people say the n-word
all right it's different that's how you
get killed you don't get mad when if a
white person
um yeah if someone's listening to music
and they say it and you get offended you
need a really rethink [ __ ] you do smack
[ __ ] have you yes
what happened tell us the story on some
real [ __ ] I I'm good I might not get it
passed but I get to pass in my head
like they're laughing about it like
they're like this dude's [ __ ] like
he's just going off I like to think that
this guy is just drank a fifth of Jack
because of the way he's speaking Yeah so
I do hope so he's nuts dude he's
hammered so dude who's this is the music
and all that you like yo yo what's good
my [ __ ] he said [ __ ] though
[ __ ] oh he didn't say my [ __ ] with the
ER yeah he said ER well if it was with
the a would you say it was just an
accent thing truly like truly like some
people come from other problems in the
country where they're grammatically
correct and they they they're
phonetically correct well then you got
to be a little bit more careful if
you're in that if then you're in that
scenario then you maybe you should be
watching how you're saying it you know
what I mean some type of way I wouldn't
do nothing I wouldn't even look at him
so what'd you do I smack [ __ ] of him he
goes to that bro
but I I hope that he's got a long fuse
you do an interview
what if I told you what the interview
was
no do you use the n-word no that's a lie
no no I don't say it it's the n word you
know what Becca the fact that that
brought just threw her man under the bus
or whatever ratted his ass out dump I do
hope he's since dumped her I'm sorry I
don't care if I kill someone and cut
them up and bury them in the Mystic
River drop them in the Mystic River
rather yeah my significant other or best
friend if someone comes up and was like
did you drop a body in the Mystic River
they're gonna and I go no they're gonna
be they're not gonna say a word or
they're gonna go what are you even
talking about of course she did it
they're not going to be throwing me
throwing me out of the bus [ __ ] threw
him under the bus I hope she learned her
lesson dump her ass no
that would be like that would be like
social suicide what is such a word of
hip-hop which is Apostle new rock and
roll so everybody wants to say it you
know but what I'll do and you can cut
this you're ready
all right you gotta be ready he's about
to preach I'm not gonna preach oh I'm
gonna rap for you to be in the club
since it's Full Throttle your [ __ ] gets
what when you see sparkles almost every
type of white person I hear says
let's hear it let's hear it
it's yours so rounded you gotta yell it
I'm trying to find out like from these
people on the street how willing are you
to say it you don't think you can fight
for yourself oh look at me now
he doesn't think he can fight for
himself
what
do you think what are you talking about
hey yes
quick interview for one dollar
what do you think about that word N word
so let me tell you something about the
n-word I travel all around the world
all around who does this the white
friend white friends
white friends white white
you're already here first from a white
man
that was pretty weird how he used to eat
like the hard R because they don't call
each other that they call each other
do you
yeah under what circumstance because
you're just yeah it's mostly loud right
yeah pretty much yeah but I'm pretty
well
yeah
oh my God if I was ever with a girl and
she said to me I'm actually pretty woke
I would literally throw up and leave
the white Americans created an insult
that's what they called slaves
why because most Americans or white
Americans did you hear or I'm Native
American
I'm Native American who do you hear it
mostly it's been the Black Culture
everyone insulting themselves it's not
an insult it's a colloquial word
it's like saying yes my God why do they
find such offense about it yeah
again it's how it said yeah I mean this
we've set our Point already I mean we
can just kind of
is there anything really super awesome
at the end of this next Tuesday yes Nico
gives his take so would you calm down
take a quick breather take a sip of the
mega pint so I'm doing this video
because as a mixed person we struggle
with this all the time you want to say
it if you want to fit in like that's
part of the culture and that's just part
of the vocabulary saying that word is
almost like fitting in that's why white
people want to say it so bad they don't
feel like they're included because I'm
around white people all the time alone
and they totally feel comfortable saying
it around me and songs in a conversation
I try to call it out but imagine every
time some dude says that you got to be
like hey uh I'm just gonna kill the vibe
real quick can you not say it when
you're singing a Kanye song well if the
Vibes are also good and no one's saying
in a bad way then what's even the point
of cutting them off and correcting them
about it if everything is good you know
what I mean yeah if it's not insulting
and mean I think that bottom line is
this this word has two meanings it has
two two Vibes two meaning everything
almost to the point oh it's like two
different words two different words yeah
I agree get both sides I totally
understand it's like
yeah you want to talk
about
the issues but if you say it and don't
expect to hear some backlash and you're
white if you say it in a group of black
people and you're like hey it's just a
word people are going to feel some type
of way people are going to have a
reaction when you say it so be careful
being
how to make you feel
you know it's important part of my
identity it's a part of the way I grew
up who I am and when people discredit
that and when they say like you're not
from the hood
sneaker's probably gonna walk like I
actually watch this video it's so funny
that he got pretty mad when I called him
pumpkin I know but he noticed that deep
down in my heart it's all jokes Nico
it's a compliment okay
for God's sake he's very logical though
I like his points yeah he's great I kind
of feel bad about the guy made fun of in
the first half of the video the guy
saying he was Native American because
someone can make the same joke about me
and the black that's in me I mean I'm
not gonna go around and say I'm Native
American
I'm black like no I'm not black I'm part
black I'm mostly Asian I look mixed I
look weird man no one knows I don't know
what you want yeah I don't know you just
you just don't feel like you belong
that's what makes people deal with like
they don't belong in one place and they
don't belong in the other to Black for
the white kids to white for the black
any final thoughts I feel like we talked
a [ __ ] ton during that straight up we
need to give each other space to make
mistakes and learn if somebody says
something that you think is like really
you know over the top give them your
perspective on it if they learn from it
I'll give them a knuckle sandwich if
they're being a [ __ ] and they
probably won't to an extent but then we
could we could say that all the people
who are hyper sensitive should give
everyone knuckle sandwiches which is
also ridiculous no because you can't be
like Will Smith How likely slapping
[ __ ] over a joke politely
educating someone on why it makes you
feel a certain way is a good thing but
like punching them in the face or
calling them a name racist [ __ ]
like maybe someone's just ignorant and
and of his particular situation and
cognum ignorant isn't helpful you want
to help somebody move forward you want
to change the world who cares about
helping that person
yes move on and do your own thing or if
you really don't care about making life
better for everybody have a have a
reasonable conversation you're racist
you're a bigger man you're a bigoted
they've shut up they've killed the word
racist it doesn't even really mean which
is a huge again it doesn't mean anything
similar to the metoo movement they
killed they killed the real meaning of
real suffering for women yeah racist
they've killed racism to the point where
now it's watered down and meaningless
and it's a shame it's a shame because
there are still real racists in the
world anyway not everybody
you're rating out of 10. you know I love
my shinigo pumpkin out of 10 better
rating am I doing this right the pumpkin
or what are you trying to do I'm doing a
heart and now it's a pumpkin
all right Nico you get a pumpkin out of
10.
[Music]